so how do you construct a computational
template from which
uh a certain kind of thing emerges so
how can you predict what emerges I
suppose so if you can predict it it
doesn't count as emergence actually I
think
that's a deeply poetic line we can talk
about I mean it's a bit like this
exaggerated doesn't count that's right
right speaking of emergence
an empowerment because we're constantly
moving between those as if they're
equals and on the team and one of them
Christoph shared with me a mathematical
equation for what does it mean to
empower nature and what is empowerment
in nature look like
um
and that relates to emergence and we can
go back to emergence in a few moments
but I want to I want to say it so that I
know that I've learned it
I've learned it I can use it later yeah
and maybe you'll figure something out as
you say it also
here but but really
um we were thinking again what does
nature want nature wants um
nature wants to increase the information
Dimension and reduce entropy what do we
want we kind of want the same thing we
want more but
um we want order right and this goes
back to your conversation with Joshua
that stochastic versus deterministic
languages or processes his definition or
the definition he found
um
was that an agent is empowered
if the entropy of the distribution of
all of it states it's high while the
entropy of the distribution of a single
state given a choice given an action is
low meaning it's that kind of uh
um
yeah Duality between opportunity like
starting like this and going like this
opening and closing and and this really
I think is analogous to to human
empowerment given
infinite wide array of choices what is
the choice that you make to
you know to to enable to empower uh to
provide you with with the agency that
you need and how much is that making
that choice actually control the
trajectory of the system that's really
nice so this this applies to all the
kinds of systems you're talking about
yeah and the cool thing is it it can
apply to a human on an individual basis
but or a silkworm or a b or a microbe a
microbe that has agency or by virtue of
of of a template but it also applies to
a community of organisms like lubies and
so we've done a lot of work sort of
moving from you've asked how to grow
things so we've grown things using
co-fabrication where we're digitally
fabricating with other organisms that
live across the various Kingdoms of Life
and and those were silkworms and bees
and uh and with bees which we've sent to
outer space and we turned healthily and
they were reproductive okay you're gonna
have to tell that story you're gonna
have to talk about the robotic queen and
the pheromones come on
um so we've built what we called a
synthetic apiary and the synthetic
apiary was designed as an environment
that was a Perpetual spring environment
for the bees of Massachusetts they go in
hibernation of course during the winter
season and then we lose 80 percent of
them or more during that period we're
thinking okay what if we created this
environment where
um before you template right before you
can design with you have to design four
right you have to create this space of
mutualism space of sort of shared
connection between you and the organism
and with bees it started as the
synthetic apiary and we have proven that
that curated environment where we
designed the space with high levels of
control of temperature humidity and
light and we've proven that they were
reproductive and alive and we realized
wow this environment that we created can
help augment bees in the winter season
in any City around the world where where
bees survive and thrive in the summer
and spring seasons and could this be a
kind of a new Urban typology an
architectural typology of symbiosis of
mutualism between organisms and humans
where these are by the way the synthetic
apiary was in a co-op in you know nearby
Somerville we had you know we had robots
our team you know slept there every day
with our with our tools and machines and
we made it happen and the neighbors were
very happy and and they got to get a ton
of Honey at the end of the winter and
and those bees of course were released
into the wild at the end of the winter
Alive and Kicking so then in order to
actually experiment with with the
robotic Queen
an idea or concept we had to prove
obviously that we can create this space
for uh for bees and then after that we
had this amazing opportunity to send the
bees to space on Blue Shepherd mission
that is part of blue origin and we of
course said yes we'll take a slot we
said okay can we outdo NASA so NASA in
1982 had an experiment where they sent b
b's to to outer space the bees returned
they were not reproductive and um
and some of them died and and we thought
well is there a way in which we can
create a life support system almost like
a small mini bio lab of a queen and her
retinue
um that would be sent in this blue
origin new Shepherd Mission uh in this
one cell and and so that's if the
synthetic APO is an architectural
project in this case this second
synthetic apiary was a product it was
right so from an from an architectural
controlled environment to a product
scale control environment and this bio
lab this life support system for bees
was designed to provide the bees with
all the conditions that they needed and
and we looked at that time at the
national pheromone that the queen uses
to guide the other bees and we looked at
pheromones that are associated with a b
and thinking of those pheromones being
released inside the capsules that go the
capsule that goes to outer space they
returned um back to our the media lab
roof and those bees were alive and
kicking and reproductive and you know
and they continue to create comb and and
it ended with a beautiful nature paper
that the team and I published together
we gave them gold nanoparticles and
silver nanoparticles because we were
interested if if bees recycle wax it was
known
forever that bees do not recycle the wax
and by feeding them these gold
nanoparticles we were able to prove that
um that the bees actually do recycle the
wax the reason I'm bringing this forward
is because
we don't view ourselves as designers of
consumable products and and
Architectural environments only but we
love that moment where these
Technologies and by the way every one of
these projects that we created
involve the creation of a new technology
whether it be a glass printer or the
spinning robot or
or the life support system for for the
bee Colony they all involved a
technology that was associated with the
the project and I never ever ever want
to let that part go because I love love
technology so much
um and but but also another element of
this is it always these projects if
they're great they reveal new knowledge
about or new science about
um the topic that that you're
investigating be it you know
silkworms or or bees or or glass that's
why I say I always tell my team it
should be at MoMA and the cover of
nature or science at the same time we
don't separate between the art and the
science it's it's it's it's one of the
same